hello my name is Admiral Rachel Levine
and I have the honor of being the
assistant secretary for health at the
United States Department of Health and
Human Services happy Pride happy pride
month and actually let's declare it a
summer of Pride happy
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's June 27 2023 and no this is not a
summer of Pride we've got three more
days of this BS and then I want you
people to feel some shame okay some
serious hardcore shame enough of this
nonsense uh all right before we do
anything else today and of course we are
live streaming on Rumble locals and
YouTube if you want to join us for the
post game show uh at
reubenreport.locals.com please do but
before we do anything I have to explain
why we are running a little late today
it is 1 p.m Eastern of course we're
always live at 11 A.M Eastern and what
happened was a couple weeks ago we were
looking to hire a new person a new
technical director we wanted a new
person on the team we're always
expanding things are growing around here
a lot of good vibes and you know the
company is always looking to bring in
good people and we get tons of resumes
dozens hundreds I don't know maybe
thousands of resumes and I say to the
guys I can't look at all of these right
resumes we have to hire the way people
hire in 2023 I said first what you do is
get rid of all the white guys you get
rid of the white people and then I said
get rid of the straight people we don't
want any straight people we don't any
want any white people and obviously the
Christians we're not going to have any
of them get rid of them too and what I'm
looking for very specifically and I said
it doesn't really matter what their
qualifications are you know technical
director you want them to have a certain
ability to to run the board they have to
know a certain amount of programs
there's some editing involved things of
that nature but I said don't worry about
any of the things that they would have
to know to do the job what I would
prefer is find me somebody and I these
were the specific things I asked for I
wanted black that was very important
lesbian or trans so black lesbian or
trans latinx okay so you got to be black
lesbian or trans the tanks you got to
have uh something either with your eye
like a lazy eye or a blindness a
temporary or permanent blindness
situation uh what were we going for the
limp we had to have the limp maybe one
leg's a little bit longer than the other
obese would be nice and and Satanist so
we did that we whittled about what was
about 762 resumes down to three
with three people that had all of those
qualifications and uh we we hired
somebody and then this morning was
supposed to be their first day and I say
their first day because it was a they
this person this whatever you want to
call this demigod or two spirit whatever
and uh did not know how to do anything
so we could not run the show this
morning and uh and here we are so that's
what happened actually what happened if
you want to know what happened Conor I'm
going to shame you to thousands of
people right now Connor God bless this
guy you've been working for me for how
many years now like over three years
you've traveled Coast to Coast with me
different states and thousands of miles
Conor has never been late he has never
missed the deadline he has never screwed
up anything once that I can think of
ever like Primo he can never leave me
employee right he overslept today he
overslept and his phone died so we were
all calling him phone not
uh ringing which got everybody concerned
my guys all live in most of them live in
in one specific building we sent Daphne
back to go knock on the door we thought
like you know what's going on here like
are we opening up to uh we didn't know
what was happening yada yada yada he
overslept
and you're not getting Chipotle today we
got a tremendous show for oh I was told
something else is happening on the Fly
since we're doing this they wanted to do
a Tuesday quiz on me since we're already
uh we're already just sort of out of
whack here with the time and everything
they wanted to throw a question at me
that I have not seen before this is
we're calling this the Tuesday quiz the
Reuben report Tuesday quiz okay very
exciting uh the question is how old do
you think Corinne Jean-Pierre is well
that's a good question how old
well they say black don't crack so she's
got to be on the young side
um
I'd say she's probably in her
early 30s how about a 32 maybe a 32.
how old she's 48. she's older than you
Corinne Jean-Pierre is 48 years old she
is older than me
God that is embarrassing because I
always think of her as a child in some
ways as much as I criticize her I'm
always like I don't want to be so
critical of her because it's like she
just got out of college
she's 48 years Man black don't crack
good for her good for her that is good
that's great that's the Reuben report
Tuesday quiz on the fly all right guys
now we have a bowl show for you and I
promise to deliver because of the
technical difficulties with our lazy eye
blah blah blah and everything else uh
there's a crazy story coming out of New
York City right now that has the the OG
New Yorkers and I know most of them have
already fled to Florida but some of them
still exist in New York City they have
just had it and it and it's perfectly
indicative of all of the insanity coming
out of our blue States and specifically
the blue cities in New York City right
now they are trying to shut down and
eliminate all the Old School pizza
places yes really they don't want them
burning coal or Wood anymore they gotta
cut emissions it is just complete
nonsense and if we were going to go
after the most like perfectly
quintessential thing the one thing that
when I go back to New York City despite
the filth and the grotes and it smells
like weed everywhere and everyone I know
is left and the few people that are
still there are depressed the one good
thing still about New York City is a
nice sloppy greasy slice of pizza and
they are coming for that too and then
we're going to link that to a whole
bunch of other things that they're
coming for including your children and
we'll get to all of that in just a
moment but let me talk to you guys about
fast growing trees guys breathe some
life into your own backyard with
fastgrowingtrees.com this spring and
summer uh from shade to fresh fruit to
privacy and natural beauty let
fastgrowingtrees.com help you plant your
dream garden with their expert advice
and fast reliable shipping
fastgrowingtrees.com's plant experts
curate thousands of easy to grow plant
shrub and tree varieties for your unique
climate Meyer lemons to Evergreens and
everything in between no more waiting in
long lines and hauling heavy plants
around with fastgrowingtrees.com you
order online and your plants arrive at
your door in just a couple days I love
fast growing trees that's where we got
our lemon and lime trees from I can't
recommend them enough and with
fast-growing trees 30 day alive and
Thrive guarantee you know everything
will look great fresh out of the box
join Over 1.5 million happy fast growing
trees customers go to fast growing
trees.com.com slash Reuben right now and
get 15 off your entire order
fastgrowingtrees.com Reuben for 15 off
and they will send you some good stuff I
guarantee it all right let's get into
Pizza people we should have had pizza
for lunch today we already ate lunch
this is a rare day that I've eaten lunch
before the show we'll see if I can still
perform uh I had quinoa with chicken
that's it okay uh here's some info from
Blaze on what's going on
New York City turn turns up the heat on
wood and coal-fired pizzerias demanding
restaurants slice emissions by 75 yes so
I just want you all to think almost
everyone watching this has been to New
York City or you can picture a New York
City pizza place that beautiful fire in
the background those big ovens some
greasy fat guy being rude to you as you
order your slice like that's what New
York City is about more than anything
and now they are trying to freaking kill
that well one guy who's not having it is
Dave Portnoy of bar stool Sports and you
guys might know that Dave Portnoy does
this what does he do it like every
couple weeks he goes he's been two
dozens if not hundreds of pizza places
all across America where he then rates
the pizza and if you get a good rating
from Portnoy on your pizza it's going to
blow up your shop in the best possible
sense so this guy freaking loves pizza
and he is not happy with these libtards
running New York City yeah
okay if everyone sent me the story
apparently in New York City
some little liberal arts ivy
league pink-haired crazy liberal who's
never worth one day in the real world is
on an environmental commission and they
woke up from their little nappy poo
wherever that may be like I figured out
how to save the world today we have to
get rid of coal oven pizzerias in New
York City we're gonna stop that the the
emissions I guess is pollution blah blah
blah you know what pizzerias use coal
ovens all the best all the best in this
environmental commission
wakes up and wants to ban coal ovens are
you kidding me do you know
what's going on in New York you got rats
you got trash in the city you got
cars planes private planes you
got people getting slashed on the subway
you got flash mobs Robin stores and
you're coming for coal oven pizzerias
you think shutting down like 10 to 15
pizza places is gonna make a difference
they've been there for 100
years I gotta come after pizzerias for
global warming are you nuts leave the
pizzerias alone
I like how somehow they bleeped all the
f-bombs except for one they went let one
slide you know it's funny because he
comes off as such a New Yorker but he's
actually from Boston or Boston as they'd
say you know uh he likes the uh the
Dunkin Donuts up in Boston uh that
wasn't a Boston accent I don't know what
that was uh but I think he gets to the
point of all of this these people who do
nothing other than ruin everything it's
very easy to destroy things it's hard to
create things you are now going to say
to the few remaining non-chain Pizza
owners there will be some chains that'll
be affected by this as well but like the
independent pizza guy whose family owned
for decades the few of them that are
still left in New York City you have to
abide by these completely arbitrary
nonsensical rules that will do
absolutely nothing and by the way
especially since covid but even before
just having a restaurant in New York
City that can survive I think usually in
restaurants in New York City have less
than one percent survival rate if you
look at them you know five to ten years
down the road the best pizza place that
I ever went to in my life was on 84th
and Amsterdam in New York City about two
blocks from where I lived it was called
Caesar's Pizza not Little Caesars it was
Caesar's Pizza it had been there for
decades this place every day from the
second day opened at 10 A.M to the time
they closed to 3 A.M it was jam-packed
constantly they closed one day out of
nowhere they were like well we can't
afford the rent anymore that was before
covet it was a very sad day for me
living in New York City at that time
when they closed that place so but that
illustrates the point it's hard to keep
a business open under the best times now
with these ridiculous regulations and
everything else but the people of New
York City finally you know you inject
them with stuff you lock them in their
buildings all that stuff okay but you
come for their Pizza they have just
about had it with um efforts here is a
New York City conservative artist his
name is Scott lobato and he went to City
Hall with some pizza to show his disgust
thank you
the woke ass idiots who run this city
are doing everything in their power to
destroy it we have naked men with their
titties bouncing around all over the
city yesterday in public in front of
children
we have the most violent raging crime
rate ever we are being invaded by
illegal immigrants who are being treated
way better than our homeless veterans
our teachers and first respond to Heroes
who were fired still not compensated
because they didn't take the fauci
injection our city schools produce the
dumbest kids and the woke ass punks who
run New York City are afraid of pizza
the world used to respect New Yorkers as
tough thick-skinned and gritty now we
have become pussified it's a damn shame
you heard of the Boston Tea Party
well this is the Boston New York this is
the New York pizza party
give us pizza or give us death
will give us death
man is there anything better like than a
New York Italian accent and just the
attitude of all that and that's what
they're trying to kill these idiots he's
right over the weekend it was Pride
weekend you've got people in dog masks
twerking in front of four-year-olds and
that we tell everybody how great that is
but you want to look at that delicious
wasted Pizza like we don't have great
pizza in Miami like that I mean I gotta
tell you you know I don't uh complain
about Florida over here but we could use
some of that we got our fancy Mr o1 in
Coconut Grove I know but we don't have
that awesome New York style pizza but
people have just had it they have just
had it I'm pretty sure that that guy
like he didn't wake up that morning like
you know I'm gonna toss some pizza over
and over the fence at City Hall but
that's what these morons these mental
midgets like mayor Eric Adams have
pushed these people into doing so here
is Eric Adams and Eric Adams you may
remember he was brought in after uh Bill
de Blasio Bill de Blasio as I think a
self-proclaimed communist he ruined New
York City okay Mike Bloomberg after the
years of Giuliani that they cleaned up
the city Bloomberg had three terms they
New York City was in an absolute
Renaissance of of cleanliness and
thriving and and just so much goodness
there de Blasio demolishes it along with
kovid and then they vote in a guy who's
basically just as bad Eric Adams and
yeah he's uh he's also a vegan by the
way you'll find out about that in just a
second uh but uh here he is on the man
who threw Pizza over the fence at City
Hall
you know every toxic
entity that we removed from our air is
adding up to the overall desire to deal
with shrinking
our carbon footprint and as I stated
let's let the public weigh in
and then we could have a conversation if
we're going to move forward or not and
the public can weigh in without throwing
Pizza over my gate they could have
delivered me to pie and allowed me to
eat the pie and sat in the you know the
cow and have a conversation with me and
so I'm going to call the person through
peace over my gate to tell him he needs
to bring a vegan pie to me so we can sit
down and I want to hear a side of this
a vegan pizza pie so this guy doesn't
even eat cheese he doesn't even eat
regular cheese and as if that that guy
had shown up to City Hall knocked on
thing hey I got some pizza for you you
want to talk as if they would have let
him in so good for you tossing Pizza
over what an absolute buffoon you know
if you took every pizza place in New
York City can you Google it Phoenix how
many how many pizza places you got in
New York City there has to be hundreds
of them but if you let's say there's 300
pizza places in New York City proper I
don't know how many in all the boroughs
but let's say there's a thousand pizza
places and you closed every pizza place
and you made sure nobody ever had a
Garlic Knot again okay you took out all
of the soda fountains there's 1200 pizza
places in New York City you took them
all out you think you would do anything
against the global warming you
Psychopaths you genuine Psychopaths
man I'm fired up at 1pm maybe we should
move the show a little bit later you
know I thought you were laying dead in
your apartment it got me it got me very
emotional this morning
but you guys get it this Crusade against
pizzerias it has nothing to do with
reality it has nothing to do with global
warning they want to control you they
want to control what you're drinking how
much soda you can have in your cup they
want to control how many children you
have they want to control whether your
children or boys or girls it is a
constant non-stop Crusade against your
freedoms that is coming from a bunch of
vegan weirdos basically so now I want to
talk to you about meat because that's
the greatest segue we've ever had for an
ad and then we'll get to the other side
let's talk about moike box you guys know
that 60 of U.S pork production comes
from one company owned by the Chinese
and their Hogs are given something
called ractopamine which is banned in
160 countries including China but it's
in your grocery aisle every day well
guys there's a better way you know all
about moink that is Moo plus oink Mike
delivers grass-fed and grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and sustainable wild caught Alaskan
salmon straight to your door you choose
the meat delivered in every box like rib
eyes to chicken breasts pork chops to
salmon fillet is and much more Eric
Adams is not going to be happy with you
plus he can cancel any time there's
nothing better than cooking my Meats on
the Big Green Egg that I got in the
backyard every Friday evening Shark Tank
host Kevin O'Leary called moink's bacon
the best bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you will say oink oink I'm
just so happy I got boinked keep
American farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of the show get free bacon in
your first box it's the best bacon
you'll ever taste for a limited time
that's
m-o-i-n-kbox.com reuben moinkbox.com
reuben tell America Adam sent you and
let's continue with this clown because
you may remember this he is a vegan and
why do people not like vegans well first
off you look at them they are always a
little green like if you wanna if you
see someone walking down the street they
don't look very good you could pretty
much figure out that they're a vegan but
okay that's that's up to them but one of
the things that I have found about a lot
of these people is that they are not
content having their diet for themselves
they always want to push everything on
everybody else this is this comes right
out of sort of the progressive mind the
the modern liberal mind it's like I it's
not just that I can live my way myself I
must actually envelope everyone in my
nonsensical worldview here's Eric Adams
declaring war on meat and dairy but the
moink people
one in every five metric tons of carbon
dioxide our city emits comes from food
but all food is not created equal
the vast majority majority of food that
is contributed to our emission crises
lies and meat and dairy products we
already know that they plant plant power
diet is better for your physical and
mental health
and I am living proof of that but the
reality is that thanks to this new
inventory we're finding out it is better
for the planet all right
first off dude there is no evidence that
a plant-based diet is better for a human
being human beings are herbivores we are
omnivores we eat herbs we eat Greenery
wheat but we're omnivores in essence
meaning we eat both right some animals
only eat herbs they're herbivores some
animals only eat their carnivores right
we're omnivores we eat both there are
plenty of people that do carnivore diets
that mostly eat meat that don't eat a
lot of vegetables and often they're
doing fine you should consult your
doctor you should make a decision on
yourself but I'm telling you you live in
New York City they're going to take your
pizza away they're going to take your
meat away you're going to be eating bugs
while that man he always wears a very
tight like somebody
breathe a little bit maybe that thing's
on maybe his collar is too tight
honestly that might be what it is they
got this freaking tight ass collar on
the guy he's not eating any meat he's
getting asphyxiated in the brain
speaking of brain is asphyxiation uh New
York Governor Kathy ochel you know that
Eric Adams is the mayor of New York City
but there's an even crazier person in
New York this is Governor Kathy hocha
now remember she's the one that took
over for Andrew Cuomo during kovid she's
one of the most vile authoritarian
people on the planet who has shown No
Remorse for any of her policies and here
she is she's very very excited that you
know now that we've reversed Roe v Wade
which was that yesterday or two days ago
was the one year anniversary of that
she's very excited that New York
basically has no bans on abortion and
that doctors in New York through
telemedicine will be able to prescribe
abortion medication for people all over
the country so that everyone can have
abortions regardless of whether you know
parents know or whether it's illegal in
that state or anything else she just
loves killing babies and she's going to
do everything she can to kill as many
babies as possible and she's going to go
on MSNBC and talk about it first of all
love what you're trying to do to help
women across the country who are in
these horrendous situations because they
can't get the health care that they need
but this measure in New York would
prohibit state law enforcement from
cooperating with any out-of-state
litigation against doctors who use
Telehealth services to prescribe
medication abortion or provide other
reproductive Health Care
so if a woman is on a Telehealth with a
doctor he's he or she is protected but
how does she get that medication in the
state that she's in because if she goes
to a pharmacy aren't they not going to
give it to her we can also have it send
to different clinics and providers but
also we're gonna we're gonna test this
you know this has not been done before
it's not been enforced and I'm prepared
to stand on the constitutional rights of
the people in this country and we'll if
someone sues us
we'll fight back because we cannot be
subjugated to these individuals who are
just weaponizing every way they can to
take away women's basic rights and we're
sick and tired of this we're sick and
tired of being victimized by people who
are at war with women in this country
whether it's the Supreme Court of the
United States whether it's republicans
in Congress or republican Governors my
what a crazy I don't know what
else to say I don't know what else to
say I've had a lot of coffee today I
guess too but I cannot take these people
and I cannot believe that anyone lives
in a state governed by these lunatics
yes someone should sue her and someone
should sue New York okay because there's
some issue about throw over state lines
and prescribe like there's going to be
all sorts this will end up in the
Supreme Court but what abortion abortion
medicine it's not medicine right like
medicine usually helps you you have a
headache for example you take Advil
Advil is a type of medicine and your
headache's gone uh when you take
abortion pills they actually kill the
child inside you so I don't know that
with technically that would be
considered medication but this idea that
it's also that they keep calling it
reproductive Health Care generally
killing babies not a big Health Care
thing you guys know I am begrudgingly
pro-choice I was completely fine with
our 15-week situation that we had in
Florida DeSantis has moved it to six
weeks I'm I'm against that personally
but I understand that he's the chief
executive of the state and everyone can
move throughout the experiment you only
want eight-month abortions go to Cali
okay we're we're doing the six week
thing here that's fine but they are
trying to now infringe on the on the
laws that other states have pushed it is
just crazy and that when this woman when
This Woman This Botox grotesque woman
when she pretends that she cares about
Constitution Regional rights or or
choice or individual autonomy or
anything else she was forcing doctors to
be fired because they were not
vaccinated against covet and you may
remember this one about how the
unvaccinated aren't listening to God
thank you God thank you and I wear my
vaccinated necklace all the time to say
I'm vaccinated all of you yes I know
you're vaccinated you're the Smart Ones
but you know there's people out there
who aren't listening to God and what God
wants you know this
you know who they are I need you to be
my Apostles I need you to go out and
talk about it and say we owe this to
each other we love each other
Jesus taught us to love one another and
how do you show that love but to care
about each other enough to say please
get vaccinated because I love you I want
you to live
God this woman lady you wouldn't know
God if he smacked you in your Restylane
filled face you really would not this is
what these people do with absolutely
everything it's it's not good enough
that they make personal choices for
themselves okay Kathy you love abortion
you want all your friends to have
abortions kill as many babies as
possible and all that stuff that's great
but she wants to make sure other people
out of state when it comes to the
vaccines she wanted to all the doctors
being fired and everything else the
nurses that were fired and then she dare
connects this to God it's just so crazy
but speaking of crazy
there is a place ladies and gentlemen
that is crazier than New York it's 3 000
miles that way yes we are talking about
California California currently has two
bills that are working through the
system right now we've discussed one of
them before uh that's
ab957 which allows courts to consider a
parent's affirmation of their child's
gender identity when making decisions
about visitation and custody so right
now this bill which we've talked about
before if you do not this is for parents
that are divorced but obviously we know
it starts there and it'll be to
everybody else if parents are divorced
and one parent is affirming the kid's
gender not the real gender but let's say
you got a boy he's 12 he says he's a
girl the dad says no you're not a girl
you're a boy uh this is just a sudden
weird thing that you're going through
and we'll work through it but the mom's
like no he's a girl he's a girl
they will literally side with the woman
take that child from the father that's
one thing that's working through right
now and then there's another bill
happening in California uh ab665 which
allows miners 12 and older
to receive mental health counseling or
therapy without parental consent without
parental consent 12 year olds okay 12
year olds who need if their class was
going to the zoo would need a consent
form but you can talk to a therapist who
you damn well know in the state of
California is going to tell you that you
are trans or two-spirit or you're a cat
or a furry or something else but that's
what they are pushing on the children of
California right now one of the biggest
proponents of this is this guy up in San
Francisco he's a Democrat state senator
named Scott Weiner and here he is
pushing this bill so that courts can
take children from parents yes literally
this this bill protects children it
makes children safer it makes children
healthier
and it's unfortunate that this bill like
so many uh has been caught up in this
this
right-wing outrage machine that it's
like every 12 hours they need another uh
another thumb another issue or another
bill uh or another or something that's
completely made up to try to just Stoke
outrage online uh to scare people to
scare parents to to feed this
um just absolutely false moral Panic
that people are running around trying to
steal people's uh children we know that
that there are children who are truly at
risk uh and and and the outrage machine
completely
undermines our efforts to address actual
Children at Risk by making pretend that
all children are somehow being targeted
and that the mental health profession is
targeting them and their teachers are
targeting them and lgbtq people are
targeting them it is outrageous and this
is a good and important bill and I want
to thank you again for moving every
single single thing he said there was
the reverse of the truth and if you
think that that guy with his nail polish
should be in charge of whether some
parent should make a decision over their
child you're crazy and if you live in
California these things are coming for
you if you have children in California
understand right at this moment all the
bill is about is about this divorce
situation so one parent doesn't want to
affirm the gender and one does right
even though they've got that backwards
again you if you were affirming
someone's gender oh you're a 12 year old
boy you're a boy congrats oh you happen
to like pink and you want to go see
Barbie Zippity damn doodah that would be
affirming their gender oh uh you're a
boy and you like pink and Barbie we're
going to chemically castrate you that
doesn't sound very affirming to me but
that nail polished weirdo wants to be in
everyone's house and yes he does want to
take people's children it's just obvious
but you don't have to listen to me just
look what's in the bill
but let's see who else this Scott weiner
weiner of course his name is weiner the
guy who wants to chop people's dicks off
here's weiner hanging out with some lady
from the sisters of Lady it's a dude
dressed as a lady from the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence which is basically
an anti-catholic hate group they just
hate Catholics now it's odd that they
don't try this with Jews and Muslims
makes you wonder but here he is I don't
know he loves this chick dude
so proud of sister Roma and her work in
the community and I'm proud of
California for standing strong
to support lgbtq people as our community
is under assault in the rest of the
country
sister Roma went on to say it's an
incredible honor to have been nominated
she says being recognized not only means
a lot to her but the lgbtq community at
large okay to be clear sister Roma is
not a sister of anything the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence are are just a
made-up imaginary thing by a bunch of
dudes pretending to be chicks in weird
Geisha costumes or whatever the hell
that is and this weirdo instead of doing
whatever the work of the state is
although I frankly I wouldn't want him
doing the work of the state because in
California the work of the state usually
ends up in your bedroom
um he's honoring this person okay let's
continue though because as you know it's
everywhere it's everywhere this is a
Reuben report first we're doing a lot of
Reuben report for us on the show today
we've never thrown back to a cold open
but here is Dick Levine now you know
dick Levine as Rachel Levine so you got
Scott Weiner and Dick Levine
I mean
we should we could close up the
operation we really could I could retire
right now because he can't make the
people look weird years from now they're
gonna look at this so you're saying you
had a guy named Weiner and Dick trying
to this is well we showed you this at
the top of the show but let's just throw
back to this you'll see why
hello my name is Admiral Rachel Levine
and I have the honor of being the
assistant secretary for health at the
United States Department of Health and
Human Services happy Pride happy pride
month and actually let's declare it a
summer of Pride happy summer of Pride
yeah let's not you freak but okay let's
continue so then
uh so then it continued here's dick
Levine talking about how gender
affirming care is actually Suicide
Prevention care and I'm going to blow
your mind with something on the other
side of this one go
you know it's it's so such an important
issue for our youth and adults as you
said some of these laws are actually
extending into adulthood you know we
often say that gender affirm and Care is
Health Care gender affirming care is
mental health care and gender affirming
care is literally Suicide Prevention
care would that be your view as well I
100 percent agree oh well you asked some
random kid whether he agrees about that
so I guess it is we we now know that
many many people and it is going to
continue to break this way that many
many people who go under these
transitions which doesn't change your
biological sex even though they pretend
it does but they chop your breasts off
chemically castrate you hormones all the
other problems with that you end up
having a penis that doesn't work a
series of other health problems blah
blah you may not look as the way you
want on the other side of the whole damn
thing now all of these people are
suicidal or depressed there's a huge
detransition movement now the ultimate
irony of this dick Levine is that dick
Levine has is on video we've showed it
to you before literally like three years
ago I think it was maybe it was four
years ago I think it was 2019 dick
Levine on video saying how happy he was
that he didn't transition until he was
an adult because he has kids so do you
know what that means dick Levine had a
dick it's unclear to me if he has one
now frankly I don't care and I don't
want to know dick Levine had a dick
impregnated his wife that he was married
to for 30 years they have kids then at
the age of 50 whatever he decides to be
a woman again I don't know if he'd
chopped the Wang off or not but now is
pushing that other children should not
what he described as his greatest joy
his two children as his greatest joy and
he is now pushing with this entire
Administration this clown car of crazy
people the idea that children should be
doing this to themselves
speaking of clown cars of crazy people
here's the vice president of the United
States
but understandings that this fight is
not over when I look at the fact that in
our country we're looking at
somewhere around 600 bills being
composed or passed anti-lgbtq
a book bag
a policy approach that is don't say yeah
people in fear for their life
spoke is afraid to be to be
fundamental issues that point to the
need for us to all be vigilant to stand
together I feel so very strongly no one
should be magnified them all and so when
it comes to the work I have done for
decades now it is the work that I will
continue to do
yeah meaningless dribble thank God she
didn't bust out a Venn diagram on that
thing uh first off as you guys know
there are not 600 anti-lgbt bills these
letters have nothing to do with each
other the t's are against the L's the
G's and the B's it's all about
protecting children and maybe not having
uh adult men expose themselves in front
of kids we all used to agree on that
that was like a kind of basic one we all
agreed on uh that's that's one thing
also she's standing that was a pride
that was Pride weekend in New York City
she's standing in front of Stonewall
that was the place of the Stonewall
riots what was that early 80s at the
height of the AIDS crisis and all of
these people there it was mostly gay men
that did not want to have to be an
underground bars to meet each other
where the bars would be broken into and
they'd be arrested and charged with all
of these things and they were fighting
for equal rights meaning the ability to
get marriage to get married and then
live a quote unquote normal life like
everybody else those people and what
they were fighting for has absolutely
nothing to do with the nonsense that
dick Levine and Scott Weiner and Kamala
Harris and the rest of these people are
talking about but who do they fear most
right oh and then of course she mentions
don't say gay which as you know the word
gay wasn't involved and there are plenty
of gay people flourishing here right in
the uh free state of Florida might I
send you to South Beach it's not my
scene but it's pretty freaking gay you
check the birdcage great movie uh but
who do they fear most they fear this Ron
DeSantis guy and check out this ad on
Ron the scary I'm DeSantis
what governor Ron DeSantis is doing in
Florida is unimaginable and his latest
policy is a modern day book burning
now the most cherished books of our time
can no longer be read by Florida
children why because Ron DeSantis has
censored them can you believe it
Classics like P is for penis or in peace
and Moby's dick have been pulled from
the shelves of Florida public schools
does your second grader want to read
Charlotte's webcam
well thanks to Ron DeSantis that book
has been banned
did you ever imagine a day would come
when children couldn't read titles like
Atlas pegged or catcher in the guy even
pitcher in the guy was taken from the
library
welcome to Ron DeSantis Florida a place
once known for being the most
erratically shaped state is now left
with zero erotic graphic novels for its
kindergarteners
and now in a Shameless Act of partisan
politics DeSantis is even going after
President Biden's beloved pop-up book
shower time
so we must act please vote Democrat
but in the meantime call the governor's
office and say you're doing me raw
is another book we demand back on the
shelves with your help we'll put
indispensable titles like The Grapes of
ass to kill a cockingbird and hundreds
of others back onto our kids reading
lists
our children are the future and we
Florida Democrats will never stop
fighting for what turns us on
paid for by the global reading
opportunities Outreach movement
you see what we did there you guys
thought that was real you thought it was
real then it takes a turn and you go
what am I looking at but it's impossible
to know truth from satire These Days to
Kill a cockingbird by the way did you
see the author on that it was El Bobbitt
do you know who L Bob it is Lorena
Bobbitt so a little before yeah you're
Lorena Bobbitt was this woman like 20
years ago I guess she was in an abusive
relationship with her husband chopped
his Wang off old school now everyone's
chopping wangs off but she was doing it
before it was cool anyway uh look there
are some politicians that are standing
up against this stuff and obviously
DeSantis is the center of the center so
he went to San Francisco last week I
think we showed you this video but it's
worth it's worth noting again because
while these weiner people and and the
rest of them while their cities turn
into dystopian L holes and they close
down pizza places and they put drugs out
on the street and fentanol is everywhere
and stores clothes and people flee and
all of that uh
some people in some places are doing it
right and DeSantis went right to San
Francisco to talk about the horrors
literally the horrors that are happening
there
we're here in the once great city of San
Francisco we came in here and we saw
people defecating on the street we saw
people using heroin we saw people
smoking crack cocaine and you look
around uh the city is not vibrant
anymore it's really collapsed because of
leftist policies and these policies have
caused people to flee this area they
don't prosecute criminals like they do
in most parts of the country and the
wreckage has really really been sad to
see and so I've seen so many businesses
boarded up I've seen so much uh Riff
Raff just running around
so you guys get it Kamala Harris
complains about books and non-existent
laws Scott Weiner and Rachel Levine
pretend that someone's coming after the
gays and the rest of it and then there
are some serious politicians that are
actually trying to deal with the issues
of the day like making sure that our our
once great City San Francisco might have
been the most beautiful city the most
thriving beautiful city 15 years ago in
America and it has become absolutely
disgusting so what they want your books
they want your words they want your meat
they want your Dairy they want your coal
they want your pizza they want your gas
stoves and guess what guys it's just the
tip of the iceberg so where do we start
with the show today well we started with
the pizza situation so one more time in
case you forgot New York city turns up
the heat on wood and coal-fired
pizzerias demands restaurants
slice emissions by 75 and you might go
well that's just kind of innocuous oh
it's New York City nobody's going to
really do it but guys there is a plan
and the plan is in full sight and it has
been in full site for quite some time we
have not shown you a video of world
economic Forum a grand Emperor Palpatine
Kyle Schwab in quite some time but here
he is in July of 2020 saying that the
next Crisis will be climate change how
he knows I just I have no idea
we know now
that the next Crisis is already waiting
for us around socomo and it is as a
climate crisis
convenient the next Crisis around the
corner and I happen to be somebody
making a lot of money with a bunch of
people who are also in their private
jets cashing in on this while
your peons will eat your your you know
your sludge or I don't believe it
Bill Gates uh who's also another one of
these weirdo lizard people here he is in
2008 with Klaus Schwab uh and uh their
interpopulation reduction which kind of
makes you think that it's weird that
they had everybody injected with this
experimental not vaccine doesn't it here
they are enjoy or don't I don't know
what what would you like to see as your
legislative Legacy in 10 15 years I
set very ambitious goals because I'm
quite optimistic if you look at say the
the 20 diseases that our Global whole
program goes after I hope that within 15
years over half of those we could have
had a very dramatic impact uh some of
them will prove to be harder than others
for example AIDS we will made an
improvement but not the dramatic
Improvement probably in that time frame
malaria perhaps and a number of the
other ones we have things in the
pipeline so you know huge change in the
uh mortality rates in developing
countries which then has this effect of
reducing population growth that's the
this big benefit that then makes
everything like education and nutrition
a lot easier do you see how twisted
these people are you see what gets him
off right there at the end oh we'll
increase mortality rate there will then
be less people so that we can have the
more educated and these These are
anti-human weirdos that's what they are
they are anti-human they want less
people I want more people and I'm not
that worried about the Earth and I think
regardless even if it was a problem for
Mother Earth if you want to have more
kids and you want to expand your family
and your community go for it don't worry
about Bill Gates also the idea that Bill
Gates is going to stop viruses is insane
what put Bill Gates on the map he
created Windows remember the Windows
operating system I always talk about it
with you had paint what else did you
have on there again you had paint that
was the only one I used you had mine
sweeper I don't know what the hell that
is yeah give me one more it's before you
guys you don't even know we had uh well
again the paint was very exciting on
there but that thing was a virus magnet
the whole reason that everyone moved
over to Apple over time was because by
Microsoft which is his company right
Microsoft Windows all of them Windows 95
Windows Omega oh my God they all got
infected with viruses and now this guy's
trying to infect us with other viruses
here he is just in the last couple
months explaining the benefits of
population decline now that he's
injected us all with this stuff not me
though uh he's pretty psyched because
there'll be less people on earth
in this year's annual letter Melinda and
I take the toughest questions we get
asked and give our answers
one that's come up for a long time is as
we make the world healthier it's the
population going to get so big that
feeding everybody and maintaining the
environment is going to be impossible
so Melinda and I wondered whether
providing new medicines and keeping
children alive would that create more of
a population problem what we found out
is that as health improves families
choose to have less children
and this effect is very very dramatic in
the 60s that reached a pretty high
number over two percent per year and
it's now come way way down
now 11 billion people still a lot but
the good news is that the faster we
improve health the faster family size
goes down and so we can feel great about
saving those lives
the less kids you have in essence have a
small family if a family at all and then
it will be good for the Earth or for him
and who the hell the Bill and Melinda
think they are they they really think
that we're in Sims remember the old Sims
game they think that they're running
that on us right now and I have to
tell you as a new father having two
children in this house it's made it a
lot more joyful and stressful and crazy
and incredible and all those things and
I'm tempted to have another one right
now just because of this freak
so how do you stop them how do you stop
them it's actually quite simple and
there is one guy who they're constantly
trying to censor and take out and
silence and everything else who has a
very simple recipe for how you stop the
Bill Gates's the Melinda Gates's the
John kerrys the Eric Adams the Scott
wieners and the dick Levines
Tucker Carlson ladies and gentlemen
yeah get married and have a ton of kids
I mean get married when you're too young
have more kids than you can afford take
a job you're not qualified for live
boldly stop getting high stop doing
anything that blurs your vision or makes
time go faster you're gonna die before
you know it don't waste a second that's
the sin is living thoughtlessly
and wasting time it's the one thing you
can't get back I've wasted a lot of
money in my life oh my gosh I don't care
I don't regret any of it but any time
that I wasted is really bitter for me
because it's finite
and so live as fully as you can and you
can't control all this stuff that's
going on you can't control what Google
does and honestly they're gonna win like
the powers that be will win at least in
the short term ultimately they'll all
blow up but like are they gonna crush me
oh yeah okay but in the meantime I want
to experience my life as fully as I
possibly can
and I think that starts with having like
a ton of kids like way more than a so
like Mormon levels of kids I mean maybe
it's not that curious why they took took
or Carlson out or at least tried to
right you get it which which makes more
sense to you you want to ride the Bill
Gates ship have less kids
have a smaller family take their
injections when they want follow all
that or do you want to do things that'll
be rewarding and give you purpose and a
reason to be here and a chance a chance
Against the Machine that as he says the
machine usually wins eventually it'll
collapse it usually does win but you
have a chance to do something right
along the way it's something that makes
you happy and gives you Joy and all that
good stuff
man one o'clock shows I want to dedicate
this show to my man Connor very happy
that you're alive my friend we were all
worried about it it was really going to
put a wrinkle in the day you know what I
mean but he's here everyone gets one
everyone gets one Phoenix you were late
once weren't you you were late once
Brock have you ever been late not yet
not yet all right interesting not yet
you have one and now you're gonna hold
it against me I know thank you guys for
watching postgame show at
reubenreport.locals.com right now
I was just thinking uh
anyway
I started off without you
and I sold a lot of State secrets and a
lot of very important things that we've
shared
[Music]